the karate kids daniel russo and cobra
kaya's daniel arusso
may have landed in two different places
but the trade-off for what we have with
cobra kai i was willing to take that one
for the team to launch the show to get
to the place where we are now so i i
kind of look a little
smart or lucky
maybe both hi i'm ralph macchio and
these are some of my iconic characters
[Music]
the karate kid
yeah of course it's really leaking there
can you come fix it
hey
what can i tell my mom when
when what
when are you gonna fix the faucet
after
after what
after after
once pat and i got together that was the
magic that you felt was special
the movie itself i had no idea yes the
guy who directed rocky was directing the
movie john g adelson so we had all those
components and robert cayman's script
was just
a wonderful but was it corny was it
people going to watch a movie about
karate is it you know the waxing cars
and painting fences and we knew the
payoff scenes the chores that were
paying off
were it was important
but would it hit on all cylinder you
just don't know that you know daniel
russo is
is an essence of of me
um probably a little more amped up with
his temper and knee-jerk i analyze stuff
a little more if i got my ass kicked on
the beach in 1984
by a bunch of motorcycle driving karate
guys i probably would leave well enough
alone where larusso it makes for a much
better movie if he doesn't but he was
the every kid next door who had no
business winning anything so therein
lies the wish fulfillment and the
aspirational
part of that that character i know how
important it was to pat to have the
authenticity and even going into the
first film into miyagi and the backstory
and his he is that soulful magic and
that depth of character and it was so
important to pat to be authentic
to this japanese-american heritage in
the case of miyagi uzokinawa so
when karate kid 2 came along and it was
about okay the other culture which was
such a smart way it had a different look
it was a love story it was a dual love
story um you took it out of the valley
so i remember the first draft of the
script i say all i do is ask questions
and the writer said yeah well you're in
another country he's like what's this mr
miyagi what's that means to me but i
said we dialed that down a little bit
and then there's that love story with
kumiko and then of course you had to
have a nemesis that was you know would
beat the hell out of daniel russo
because of what's karate kid without
daniel russell getting his ass kicked
and getting in trouble and going back
for more you know that's sort of the
recipe and it's kind of ahead of its
time
certainly in the karate kid the whole
japanese internment camp that was the
first
uh major motion pictures hollywood
studio movie that ever addressed
that sort of dark time in our history so
as much as you could talk about karate
kid being a popcorn movie of the 80s it
had those elements and that's what
separates it karate kid 3 was a
challenge i always felt that script
didn't find the freshness for daniel
arusso going forward it was about okay
we had the crane kick in the first movie
you had all the magic of the chores and
the lessons and karateka 3 was more
about the kata and the the different
types of
martial arts
cobra kai
[Music]
by the time we got to now we're jumping
you know 30 something years later
everything hurts a little more takes a
lot longer to stretch it's injury
prevention at this point i got away with
one good kick what kind of karate
training
yeah well in karate kid in the first
film i had about five weeks of training
and it was simplistic training because
that was the whole point it's about
avoiding getting hit and it's karate for
defense only and it wasn't about attack
and big fight sequences and it's still
that way that goju style of miyagi's
karate it should be two three
moves and out that's the whole point
it's not it's not to have a knock-down
drag out
you know kind of thing it's getting
yourself out it's self-defense you know
the thing is billy and i billy's and i
talk about this we did a sequence uh
where we have a sort of rematch
score one-o lawrence
[Music]
it was really important for us to
play it from the perspective of what
what the characters stakes were it was
about we were trying to do what was
right
for the kids in the show it wasn't about
two guys now in their 50s
rematching their 18 year old fight 17
year old fight you know we don't move i
don't spring back the way i did when i
was 21 so we wanted it to be true to how
guys at this age would fight it so it
had its own
uh feel to it i was really proud of that
i was proud that it came from the
perspective of the characters
and it came from the perspective of the
guys at this age and we weren't trying
to do a fight like say tanner and show
low two of our young studs in the cobra
kai cast or jacob for that matter they
they're so incredible they're like
acrobatic as big and as heightened as
the tone of that series gets and how the
san fernando valley is like a superhero
like it's like thanos is in a ghee on
ventura boulevard and he must be stopped
it's grounded in the characters you care
about and the heart and the soul that is
always ingrained in the source material
which was the karate kid and you know
it's fathers and sons and mentors and
and overcoming obstacles and as long as
that heart is there is we care and in in
cobra kai also it's important to have
miyagi
woven throughout the show i couldn't
have signed on unless that was part of
the plans i'm really proud of that and
the writers do a great job i've been
thinking about you a lot lately i um
you know it's
it's funny
when i was a kid you
seemed to always have all the answers
and i guess i thought when i got older
i'd have it all figured out too what
really engaged me during the pitch and
it was so well thought out and i had
just seen um creed and that's sort of
like how do you come into the rocky
balboa story from another angle the
attention they paid to the young cast
the you know the miguel character the
robbie character the samantha character
and seeing the future of the next
generation of karate kids if you will
that was the stuff that was the most
engaging where larusso sat in the world
was not necessarily what i would have
written i joke with them even to this
day our our three creators you know i
say at what point did you start thinking
of okay how does this work uh what's the
honesty for daniel russo you could feel
that the initial concept is like okay
here's johnny lawrence how could we make
his life as miserable as possible what
could we have larusso be doing that
makes it worse for him make him a car
dealer make him on billboards he's on
television commercials so then i'm like
okay what's the honesty for larusso at
that point there's a push and a pull
there
and it was about the long game
fortunately the series is going long you
know i would always argue larusso had
this great mentor this grounded mother
would he really have gone in this
direction of being a guy
who wanted the camera on himself who
used his one kick to rub in the face of
everyone the earlier stuff was even
more in your face it was once i got to
episode five and season one
once he goes he he stops his wife amanda
almost makes him realize that he's lost
his focus and he goes to miyagi's grave
and has that conversation with mr miyagi
and wishes he was there from that point
on even though he slips and falls and
gets a little arrogant here and there
that's when the show started to find its
balance there's that balance word and
then now on in season four and five um
you know all of that as you get you peel
all the layers and go into the gray
areas of all these characters of the
show he never lets go of of wanting to
to teach the ways of his mentor and
realizing how important that is
to have and his his family his life his
business his friendships i would love to
see the miyagi origin story what was
life like for him where does that go
what happened in world war ii and when
he came to the
u.s and wound up you know a maintenance
guy in the san fernando valley apartment
building until this kid knocked on the
door
my cousin vinnie
[Music]
bill gambini was you know
listen they set up the movie him and
stanley rothenstein you know two college
kids driving across the country
accidentally takes a can of tuna and we
set up one of the funniest american
comedies in cinema it really is
uh
you know dale lorner wrote a script that
just
i call it a late for dinner movie if my
cousin vinnie is on you're gonna be late
for dinner it was not the easiest part
to get
um because at that point
1991
the
you know the outsiders the karate kid
had sort of peaked and i was
you know
getting close to 30 and still looking 20
but once i got in the audition that
ended right away and it worked out you
know well and i'm really proud to have
that one it was that casual cousin that
everybody knew we got an attorney in the
family great who my cousin vinnie so it
was about finding that and defining that
and it was really
in those scenes with the great bruce
mcgill played a sheriff farley i love
those scenes with him people come up to
me with cancer tuna and says you're
right i shot the clerk i said only if i
put a question mark at the end of it and
then what we went out to the car
and that's it
when's your shooting
what
at what point did you shoot the clerk
i shot the clerk yes when did you shoot
him i shot the clock
the stuff in the courtroom was more
challenging because uh for me with 10
hour days with big courtroom scenes
where you're shooting one direction then
you shoot another direction joe was uh
he just um i had met him a few times i
was on broadway
uh with robert de niro in 86 in a play
called coumadis teddy bear and and joe
uh came to see the the play i think
that's the first time i met him joe
doesn't like to rehearse a lot
where i usually i like the comfort of
that sort of theater experience of
rehearsing he
likes to you know why why waste it when
you could capture it and i understand
that he just had that guy down him and
marissa had a you know that special
special chemistry it was important that
they had each other's backs it's all
about family right it's that old school
i could have the best harvard lawyer to
get me off the murder charge
but i know my cousin i've seen him in a
room he will figure out a way and
there's a nice moment at the end of that
film when after they win the the case
it's a kind of teary-eyed moment and
it's a comedy but this is a high stakes
the toughest thing with my cousin vinnie
is when i read
the script and the scene where joe comes
in the prison cell vinnie comes in the
cell and i'm sleeping
and uh roth is stan rothenstein thinks
he's there for something else i'll let
him sleep a little bit
look i don't want to do this hey i don't
blame you if i was in your situation i'd
want to get through this whole thing as
quickly and with as little pain as
possible so you know let's try our best
to make it a simple in and out procedure
and when i read that in the script it
was one of the funniest scenes on the
page and i when they
you know when i auditioned i said can i
play the jewish guy rothenstein i'm
seeing it fortunately there were more
than just one favorite scene in the
script
the outsiders
[Music]
it seems like it's got to be someplace
without grazers
socials
[Music]
must be someplace
just
plain ordinary
people
people
johnny kate and the outsiders was the
you know kind of
role of a lifetime for me certainly at
that point and still holds a special
place i read that book when i was 12
years old and that's when i immediately
had a connection with this character not
necessarily parallel that my life was
his life thankfully for me the outsiders
was the first book that i read
cover to cover without my parents saying
you know you have to read again tonight
before school tomorrow it was a page
turner written by a 16 year old girl sc
hinton susie who's
i'm still friends with to this day
hinton was on the set from the get-go
and during the rehearsals because
francis and her wrote the screenplay and
she tells me the story
she was nervous about johnny it wasn't
until we did the table read
she said she went to france and she says
now i can sleep that book and all those
characters had
someone
someone could relate to in some way
johnny was always written as the runt of
the litter the smallest of the group i
was always
you know the youngest looking in my
class something i'm still working on i
had sympathy and empathy for him that he
was from a broken home and and needed
these guys these other greasers to be
the family that he felt a part of you
know reading the book at 12 i was
beginning to feel that when i heard they
were making a movie and then i heard it
was being directed by francis ford
coppola and that audition process i just
i just wanted that role so bad i didn't
want any other role he cast that film
with everyone all the actors being in
one room he wanted to mix and match and
see who connected and see and create
that ensemble any time he asked me they
said well you could read two-bit or you
could read soda poppy and i said well
but i'm here i'd like to read for johnny
you know this is the this is the guy i
was like casting myself so the balls of
me to do that i mean just to be in a
francis ford coppola movie i was like no
i want to be in this movie playing this
role and he still is a character one of
my favorite performances and
and uh favorite experiences and that
cast rivals any cast ever put together
hey johnny man
what are you doing bro
things go a lot better the social state
on the south side of town now why don't
you worry about that johnny cause we're
gonna have it out with them sooner or
later
those are the same guys that got you
no
no all the guys we rehearsed for about
two weeks which is rare so we had a
little bit of a theater camp going
france's like to create that and one of
the one of the things early on he looked
at me goes you're too long island you're
too put together i want you i'm gonna
give you like five dollars and that's
all you have to spend the whole day
and you need to get three meals out of
it and you need to find a place to sleep
and all this stuff so i slept out in a
park you know with newspapers kind of on
me it was cold but i i wound up turning
in probably about three in the morning i
didn't stay out there all night but it
was like just playing it was like an
acting lesson it's like a little bit of
a method you know experience if i
haven't experienced that you know the
scene in the hospital post the church
fire johnny you okay
yeah
just hurts sometimes
usually don't
because i can't feel anything below the
middle of my back
pretty bad off ain't nothing boy we shot
that that was one day and i wound up
just staying in there all day
um never got up once i just stayed in
this for probably 12 hours
and because that's what it would be
um he had no family really he just had
the greasers and uh and the guys and i
said how do you play a broken back and
burns like i don't you know i could play
being hurt by someone being heartbroken
it was just really about just
taking those moments like the isolated
moments and the and the quiet moments
and just knowing that this one that life
has changed forever at the end of the
film and ponyboy opens the book and gets
the letter from johnny and it's this
beautiful moment i'm just kind of you
know just reading telling him
understanding a little bit about what
nothing gold can stay means
stay gold
ponyboy
right time right role
and lucky for me it worked movies are
defined based over time i mean you could
go down the list and say apocalypse now
or the godfather but if you ask someone
what won the oscar two years ago they
forget they become
what they are over over time and you
know with the outsiders and my cousin
vinnie and the karate kid for that
matter they have stood the test of time